Okay, so I'm going to talk a little bit about cookie
expiration real quick and then we will move on. So
let's let's, let's get our cookie. Okay, so, this cookie
we've been working with. I've added an extra, an extra little
parameter here called Expires. Which basically gives the cookie an
expiration date. And this means the browser will hang onto this
cookie until Tuesday, January 1st, 2025. That means you can
close your browser you know, close your tab, whatever, come back
to this website and the cookie will still be there. And if you
don't include this Expires parameter, the
cookie will expire. When you close your
browser. That's called a session cookie.
A session cookie, you know, basically has
no Expires parameter. And so it'll disappear
when you, when you close your browser.
So depending on what you want to do, you know, if you want,
you know, how when sometimes you login? You know, you might, you might
have a login on, on, on, on a website. That has, you know,
takes a user name and password and it has a checkbox for remember me.
Basically what you're triggering here when you, when you check
this check-box is, whether or not to set an Expires parameter.
So if you don't check it there will be no
Expires parameter. And you'll be logged out when you close your
browser. And if you do check it. Your, your cookie
that you get when you login will have an Expires parameter.
So that's generally what's going on there. You just deciding
whether or not to include this extra parameter on your cookie.